so when returned to the Jedi came out I
was like 7 years old and a friend and I
entered a trivia contest down at the
mall and we won second place and we both
got a huge dishwasher size cardboard box
full of Star Wars merchandise I could
not have been more excited about it and
then I opened it up and ninety-five
percent of it was Darth Vader belt
buckles and Princess Leia shampoos and
like one IG 88 figure but we still got
second place my favorite part in Star
Wars is the trash compactor scene where
Luke Han and Leia's start cheering but
c-3po still thinks that they're being
slowly crushed to death I remember being
a kid in coming home from a Star Wars
movie and being very excited about
lightsabers in college I was super
stoked for episode 3 to come out but
then I took a really hot date out to see
the movie and she really hated it was
super violent and it was just a flop my
favorite part is when the guy with big
head crashes into the control panel
Spaceballs what are we talking about
when I was a kid I used to go dumpster
diving at the egg factory looking for
artifacts that would give some clue as
to what was happening in the next movie
I never actually found anything except
once i found a retrieved a message pad
that had a phone message indicating that
steven spielberg had called and please
call him back that was I think after
empire and before raiders of the lost
ark and eventually stopped doing it in
preparation for the story I watched all
six movies in one weekend it was
exhausting my favorite scene is star
wars are the opening credits from
episode 4 I remember seeing in the
theater as a kid and every time I see it
since then I still got that same
emotional charge that I did that very
first time so my favorite part is where
Vader is commissioning all of the bounty
hunters to chase han Solo all of these
crazy reptilian and robot characters
that you never see anywhere else in any
of the movies yet those guys are my
favorites okay I'm just going to say it
I heart Jar Jar Binks I'm here to defend
star wars episode one sure it had
annoying characters like Jar Jar Binks
and terrible racing scenes but it had
the most badass character in the entire
saga Darth Maul
as an eight year old Star Wars fan I
used to trim out little paper Ewoks tape
them to the bottom of my paper airplanes
to recreate those end or scenes my
favorite Star Wars moment is the part in
Empire where Lando gets eaten by the
sand monster because I never liked that
guy I'd say an empire when Lando
Calrissian betrays Han Solo some about
when that door opens and Darth Vader
stands up in that all white room and
Boba Fett comes in behind and Han Solo
without even thinking pulls his blaster
opens fire Darth Vader just blocks it
with his hand everyone in that scene is
an utter badass so me and my roommate's
were sitting around I recently purchased
a projector and we're watching the Star
Wars films the original ones and we SAT
around talking about how when we were
kids we didn't get to see it actually in
movie theaters but all of us actually
very distinctly remember the size of the
TV that we watched it on and me and my
brothers when we were kids watch it on a
TV about this big so it was a much
better experience this time around best
line from Star Wars when Han Solo the
slices open the taunton says I thought
they smelled bad on the outside just
shortly after I turned 21 I went to a
science fiction convention in Florida
and I was dragged up to a room party by
some of my friends that's where I saw
the star wars holiday special on VHS and
I heard rumors about this and this was
pre-internet I got to see Bea Arthur as
the owner of the cantina and the
original appearance of Boba Fett they
didn't want to be there they were
contract early obligated to be there and
because of it it makes almost the
perfect thing to watch as a Star Wars
fan if you're intoxicated if you're
watching it sober it's horrible my
favorite Star Wars moment is well I
actually haven't seen them
you